it's great to welcome to the program
today eric garcetti who is the mayor of
los angeles california
also national co-chair for joe biden's
campaign
played an integral role i am told in the
selection of kamala harris
as the vice presidential running mate
for joe biden
to start with mayor as you've watched
the first presidential debate and the
vice presidential debate
i know that we partisans tend to see
much of what we want to see in terms of
who does who does best but
analyzing it in terms of whether it
moved the needle at all what what do you
think
you know i think it reinforced what
people think about these candidates
in the first debate i was there in
cleveland it was the first trip that i
took i had no idea
i would be exposed to uh covet 19 by our
commander-in-chief and and his
uh some of his supporters and family
that said
just if you even turned down what the
words
say watching somebody interrupt uh
the other candidate when donald trump
was interrupting joe biden it showed
that he didn't have respect not only for
him as
as his opponent but for us you know i'm
somebody who's run for office i think
it's important for you to hear what i
have to say
and what my opponent has to say because
if you have the strength of your ideas
you don't need to interrupt people and i
think
that's really the biggest contrast is
you know especially with
women who are now almost 30 points ahead
with people are just sick and tired of
the chaos
that trump has brought to this country
and he brought that same chaos to the
stage
the vice presidential debate while it
came in a slicker package
while certainly you have an accomplished
debater
in vice president pence uh he barely
answered the questions
um it was i called it flies and lies
because of the famous fly that lie
that landed on his head but all kidding
aside you know
he also interrupted this is the playbook
you know talk over people um
and deny you know the science deny when
it comes to
climate change or coped 19 deny the
facts and try to reshape them
and i think people are finally seeing
through that you can maybe convince
people before you're in power
but after four years when they can
materially see what you've done to
damage the economy
how many lives have been lost and we
feel that in a personal way i think
there's never been a clear contrast in
an election in our lifetime
yeah and and i think on the vp debate
the fact that the most memorable moment
involved in insect um
tells us you know quite a bit really i
mean it's funny but it's also a real
you know real real consideration um one
of the
sort of uh concerns that exists when
looking at
the joe by what what joe biden's first
term would look like if indeed
he gets one is that while on paper and
i've made the case that on paper joe
biden's platform
would make him the most progressive
president in history i mean on climate
he's to the left of obama
on health care he's to the left of obama
no i don't think there's any doubt there
when the news is that he's looking at a
pretty significant number of republicans
for the cabinet
you start to see some of those reluctant
maybe bernie supporters
warren supporters who do plan to vote
for biden worry
that the paper platform will not
really translate to a cabinet what is
your take on that
well first of all somebody who
co-chaired the vice presidential search
says i would believe nothing of the what
we used to call
in the navy rumor intelligence we called
it rument
there's a hundred rumors for everything
that's going on though i do believe that
those are not mutually exclusive i do
believe that uh
we will see and joe biden a president
for all of america unlike donald trump
who
looks at a state paints it a color and
decides whether he's going to help
we do need a president who will govern
for everybody regardless of whether
they're democrat
independent or republican but that
doesn't and it won't come at the expense
of the policies we've laid out in other
words we haven't put platforms out there
that we're going to run away from in an
administration you will see joe biden
and kamala harris see through
um you know getting to carbon neutral
electricity in this country by 2035
something unthinkable
to hear out of a presidential candidate
just a few years ago you will see a
massive infrastructure investment in a
new green infrastructure but i do think
it's important to have a cabinet that
reflects america
that has been a tradition generally
where you have in republican
administrations a democrat or two
and vice versa in a democratic
administration a republican or two
because
you want to have that unity in the
country but that's not going to come at
the expense of what we're going to do on
health care on housing
what we're going to do on the
environment when it comes to racial
justice those things
are part of why joe biden's running for
president and what this campaign is all
about
and what we're going to do when he wins
yeah and i guess
to the extent that nothing is given up
in order to have
a republican or two i i think that it
makes makes a lot of sense i guess the
concern
comes in when you see very ambitious
climate proposals as as you're pointing
out
if you have a republican secretary of
transportation
and energy it starts to become it starts
to at least
seem like it would be less likely but
you you think it will be
modestly calibrated and this is not
going to be uh
some some actual centrist cabinet no not
not at all i mean i
look it's good to have diverse
perspectives but when you run with a
platform your platform is your blueprint
and you don't run away from that no
matter what so you hire people who are
interested
in the boss's vision the boss is joe
biden
this isn't something done by committee
he has said if you
trust me as your next president this is
what i will
do there's no hedging of that 100 full
stop
that is what this administration will
bring to america
not because it scores political points
it's what we need our earth is burning
our fires
are record uh our air is choking we're
seeing floods everywhere
you know i chair c-40 cities which is
the 96 largest
mayors sorry cities of the world's
mayors combating climate change
so i see this every single day talking
to folks from japan and china and india
and africa
and south america and australia this is
real and finally we're going to see an
administration that steps up to this
moment not just restores
are signing on to the paris climate
accord but takes many steps forward
and engages the international
conversation that we need
it's also one last thing good not just
for the environment but good for our
economy
this is where job growth is occurring
that's what we've experienced in la
with our green new deal in los angeles
and we will see at the national level
that same
progressive and green vision um last
thing i want to touch on
from the standpoint of how this election
is going to actually happen we're seeing
record early voting although we don't
want to read too much into that because
we've seen record encouragement of early
voting
in the context of the pandemic i
wouldn't look too much at that we're
seeing
national polling that looks solid for
joe biden
but this is an electoral election not a
popular vote election so we want to be
careful there
and when you look at some key states
like pennsylvania michigan and wisconsin
two weeks out right now compared to two
weeks out four years ago
it's actually quite similar the numbers
are quite similar from what we had
between hillary clinton and donald trump
in those key states
so question one what are you looking at
in terms of your assessment and and
number two
when do you think we will have election
results the president has fear-mongered
around
it could take months i don't believe
that for a second but
it could take days it could take 10 14
days what kind of timeline are you
looking at
so those are great questions david and
you know i do think something's a little
different than four years ago i think
people are less shy about
answering in polls whether they're going
to be voting for donald trump and i do
think that this has been about as steady
polling as i've ever seen in an election
even
even in 2016 it was up and down and this
has been just
constant i think people are locked in
but we've never had an election like
this
we've never had an election in a
pandemic in the modern era
we don't know how those votes will be
counted you're right it's easy to see
the early voting but those are the most
enthusiastic people
who know how to vote who are motivated
to vote and it's really about those
folks that are busy with their lives who
are stressed by the economic situation
who might not know how to vote by mail
and have never done it those are the
folks who are really focused on and
regardless of your party i hope
everybody can protect those votes and
encourage those votes
we're using the portal iwillvote.com
where you can find out all the
information
in your state about how to vote and make
a plan to do that
and i think that if that is executed we
will win this but in terms of when we'll
know
you know there's some states that are
key swing states that are
able to start counting those votes early
in places like ohio so they're already
doing that as they receive them
other states and florida as well other
states go a little bit more slowly and
take some time in places like
pennsylvania so it all depends on what
that margin
is but i do think that look i believe
very strongly we're ahead in
every swing state we're going to win
arizona i feel with confidence if we can
execute these last couple weeks
we're going to see potentially some
pickups of new states we haven't seen in
a while
be in the democratic column and maybe
bring some back that have strayed
so we have so many different paths to
victory for joe biden
uh you know donald trump has to run the
table
and i hope that part of running the
table for him is not denying the vote
it is not uh looking at trying to
encourage
uh supporters to depress the counting of
the vote like we saw
uh in florida during the bush gore
debacle
this is a moment which all of us as
americans need to respect the vote joe
biden has said if i win or lose
i will respect the vote we still haven't
heard that out of the words of the
president
so it falls on us to save our democracy
if our president won't
yeah on on that note and i know i know
you've got to run
we know that the trump campaign has
lawyers ready to
challenge the counting of absentee
ballots and and basically go to the
courts
at midnight on november third are you
confident that the biden campaign
is also prepared sufficiently with
lawyers to challenge that
absolutely we have 17 states set up
we've been doing it for months we have
so many lawyers activists other people
who have volunteered who will do it the
right way this is not about
mob rule this is not about pressuring
folks to count or not count this is
about looking at each one carefully
making sure
every state no matter who runs the
elections adheres to the law and that
every vote is counted that's the most
basic
right that we all have as americans i
hope we can all stand up for that but
for those who would attack it
we are prepared yeah listen if joe biden
loses fairly we will deal with that um
but if it's a different scenario then
that's a very different uh america that
that we're talking about we've been
speaking with eric garcetti mayor of los
angeles california
thank you so much for your time today
thanks david really great to be with you